bertrand's barbershop is a space to talk
between trimming and styling one
conversation is especially important
people here can open up about cancer
he knows about the disease and the pain
it causes first-hand losing his dad to
bowel cancer last year
i think it had been a taboo almost for a
very long time i think especially in the
ethnic culture where
we tend not to discuss these things um
not even just health it's just anything
personal
and so for a long time even family
members didn't know that he had cancer
his shop is now part of a macmillan
project its aim to help make those
difficult discussions easier so what
bertrand is able to offer along with the
other barbers that are part of this
network across london is to actually
offer us time where men can engage can
speak freely in a safe environment where
discussions about all manner of things
comes up and from time to time things
around health care can be raised i look
back and think yes i was in a dark place
one person who comes here to speak out
is sean he survived cancer and thinks
it's important people get screened early
i said to people that there's a good
chance that if you were okay before
you're likely to be okay afterwards
to help save lives conversations about
cancer can't just stay in the barbershop
though people need to be seen by doctors
and in poorer parts of the country like
newham gps are still referring cancer
patients far too late
over the year we have referred 55
patients as a practice but 22 of them
have been just in the last three months
this gp is seeing more cancer patients
than ever many from minority backgrounds
are putting other things first
newm has had the highest furlough rate
if you're thinking about feeding your
family in thinking about your cancer
screening test might not be the first
thing on your mind if you've got a
little bit of for example blood in your
we you might just ignore that you might
not have the time to go and see your
doctor
i think this picture like summons him up
really really well bertrand has used his
memories to begin a mission he hopes the
more minorities speak out and seek
support the less daunting they will find
this disease shinki marike sky news